DAVID STERN: We're living on the cusp of a new media age.
Actually, we're already deep into it.
And when scholars can tear their eyes away from the computer screen,
they've looked back upon the history of the book.
Now for Jews, no book has figured more centrally,
more profoundly in their history, than the Bible--
the Jewish Bible.
By the phrase "a Jewish Bible," I mean the Hebrew Bible
that Jews have actually held in their hands
and used, not the text, but the physical object,
whether it's been a scroll like the monumental Torah scroll, or a book.
In the course of history, the material features of these scrolls and books
have changed dramatically.
Jews have developed laws and rituals around them.
The objects themselves come to possess their own symbolic meaning.
This course requires no previous background
in Jewish history or Judaism.
But it will take you on a tour of Jewish history
from the ancient period down until today.
This course will teach you about many things--
about the Bible, about Judaism and Jewish history, about Jews, Christians,
and Muslims, and how they've interacted.
But more than anything else, it will teach you
that a book is more than just words on a page, but as an object,
it has a life of its own that is worth pondering and understanding.
[MUSIC PLAYING]